Det svåra är att vi bedömer varumärken utifrån vår egna livsutfarenhet.
Det är många kreatörer som tycker att det är toppen och tycker att det är så man ska göra.
Som strateg tycker jag att det är jättefarligt.
Make Sweden Stronger.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger det.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Mats Gehorsson som är varumärkesexpert till podden.
Det här är en person som inte jag har haft sådär jättemycket koll på eftersom jag mest har koll på e-handelsfolk.
Men däremot så har jag liksom blivit pushad av ett antal människor som verkligen verkar vara hängivna fans till dina visaord Mats.
Och då är jag lite nyfiken på vad det är du kan lära ut här till oss idag.
Känner du igen när de har hört av sig till det och sagt att fan, han Joel, nu har vi legat på honom.
Ja, det har jag faktiskt hört ifrån två personer att de har tipsat dig och sådär.
De har inte tipsat en gång.
De har tjatat med andra.
Där ser man hur det är när man har byggt varumärker.
Det är också väldigt tydligt för att, det finns ju alltid folk som tipsar om att ta med den här i borden och så hamnar det i någon sorts, du vet, anteckningslista av.
Här är 50 pers jag ska höra av mig till.
Anledningen till att jag väldigt väl vet att de har tipsat om dig är att du har ett väldigt intressant bildspråk på LinkedIn.
Så det är väldigt lätt att komma ihåg.
Så när jag går in och liksom klicka på länken så blir väldigt tydligt, ah just ja, ja men här har jag varit inne förut.
Jag tänker att vi får komma tillbaka till det sen, men kan du inte bara ge oss en liten, en liten snabb intro om vem du är och vad du har gjort och du kanske inte var det gilla för mat liksom, men, men vem är Mats?
Nej men, jätteroligt sådär.
Jag brukar berätta min story såhär att när jag gick på gymnasiet fortfarande så var jag jättetrollbunden av reklam.
Så jag upptäckte det som en, vad ska man säga, som en art and science och satt och läste nördigt nog på tunnelbanan på väg till plugget.
Historierna, liksom de här stora reklamguruserna från 60 och 70-talet, hur de tänkte och så vidare.
Det var ju väldigt fascinerande stories, de gick ju all in, de var ju tvungna att tänka liksom i förväg för att när du väl körde en kampanj då satte du i princip hela framtiden på sin spets.
Antingen funkar och då blev allting jättebra, eller så var det en flopp och då blev det katastrof.
Och så såg jag hur mycket jobb de gjorde under och då blev jag ännu mer fascinerad.
För först så tyckte jag bara att det var läckert med de här roliga idéerna och kuliga greppen och produktionerna, men sen blev jag ännu mer fascinerad av det här oerhörda djupet och de la på att försöka riskminimera i den mån det var möjligt.
Att göra research, tänka efter, koppla det till affären och allt det där.
Och jag bara bestämde mig så att det här vill jag göra.
Så jag drog till USA, doktorerade ganska ung och sen så kom jag ju med väldigt tidigt i strategiska sammanhang och sånt där.
Så jag halkade in på Ericsson när det liksom gick som tåget och var väl första marknadsföraren som nuddade vid det som blev Bluetooth och så där.
Lade grunderna där marknadsföringsmässigt och sen så var jag också med att starta Sony Ericsson istället för Ericsson och då som global varumärkeschef.
Och fick just den här, aha, upplevelsen väldigt tidigt, att varumärke byggs av att man är alltså att det är regent för hela affären.
Man går inte bara ut i reklamen, paradoxalt nog, för det är där jag började.
Utan det är allt som skapar det här.
Och då fanns det inga konsulter som gjorde det här heller.
Så jag blev konsult, har hållit på med det i ungefär 25 år.
Och jobbar med någonstans runt 150 företag skulle jag tro.
Och sen har jag också hunnit med att i tio år vara lektor på deltid på Stockholms universitet och undervisa i det här på alla möjliga nivåer.
Så det är liksom vad jag har gjort.
Vad är den största felkopplingen som folk gör när du säger att du jobbar med varumärk och marknadsföring?
Vad är det folk tror att du gör?
Men vad är det du gör egentligen?
Alltså det finns ju tusen olika missuppfattningar.
Men kanske den vanligaste är ju att man är designer, att man ritar loggor.
Och allt är viktigt liksom.
Jag ska absolut inte ta något ifrån det.
Men det är ju ungefär som att säga att din underskrift liksom är det som bygger gymkompaniet.
Alltså det är ju bara en absoluta spetsa.
Utan det är ju egentligen i princip att man är ett stöl för vd och ledningsgrupp.
Att bli mer marknadsorienterad, att hitta sin roll.
Att verkligen mobilisera, att kunna möta marknaden bättre.
Och egentligen skapa så mycket momentum som möjligt innan man ens tänker på reklam eller design och sådant där faktiskt.
Så det är väldigt hög grad ett strategijobb, så att säga med det där, som man kanske kan tänka lite mer tråkigt, liksom management-konsulteri.
Men samtidigt man gör det med den här utifrånperspektivet och den kreativa edgeen så att det blir någonting av det.
Vi pratade lite här, precis innan vi drog igång så utbytte vi liksom ett par meningar och då hamnade vi ganska snabbt i den nya tidens marknadsföring kontra oldschool-marknadsföring.
Du kanske inte kallar det så, men att nu är det kanske mer skryva på en marknadsbudget som ska dra in ett visst antal konverteringar kontra någonting annat.
Kan vi inte bara fastna lite i den diskussionen och kan du förklara vad det är jag egentligen försöker säga men inte kan säga?
Nej men absolut för den är viktig.
Jag tror alla är överens om det.
Marknadsfunktionen och därmed också marknadschefen har blivit mer en specialistroll.
Att man sitter och ägnar sig åt bara en del av det som egentligen är marknadsföring, det vill säga kommunikation.
Att man funderar på hur man ska på olika sätt använda budgetar och olika kanaler för att kommunicera mot marknaden.
Det är absolut inget fel på det.
De där specialisterna är jätteviktiga och på flera ledvar.
För dels behöver du någon som är duktig på helheten inom den sektorn.
Sen behöver du alla specialister som fattar de här olika kanalerna och all martech som finns idag och så vidare.
Det är komplext.
Men det har blivit en silo och det är jättedåligt för företagen.
Därför att då hamnar saker mellan stolarna.
Vem är det egentliga som äger?
Vad ska företaget ha för kunder om 2-3 år?
Vad behöver vi fundera på inom produkt?
Vad behöver vi ta in för information om marknaden?
Hur ska vi styra allt det här?
Vilken prissättning ska vi ha?
Hur ska vi paketera våra erbjuden i framtiden?
Alla de här sakerna var en gång i tiden.
Vad marknadschefen gjorde är idag ett vakuum.
Då hände två saker.
Dels hittar folk en massa nya, hittar påtitlar åt höger och vänster.
Det andra är också att företagen tappar innovationskraften.
Därför att det är fragmenterat och till slut så blir det liksom så här att man får inte momentum bakom att samordna sig.
Så det tycker jag är det som har hänt och det jag verkligen tänker slåss för att vi måste ta tillbaka i ledningsgrupperna.
Att hela ledningsgruppen ska jobba med marknadsföring.
Menar du att det har liksom försvunnit det tänket eller menar du att det bara har blivit sämre för att det hamnar på massa olika personer och ingen tar ansvar för det?
Vad är det vanliga?
Ja alltså det finns så många olika saker att prata om i det här området som har gjort att vi har hamnat här.
Jag tror att...
Varför har vi hamnat här kanske vi ska börja idag?
Ja exakt.
Som sagt det digitala gjorde var en väldigt skurk i det.
Anledningen är egentligen att enda sen jag började jobba med marknadsföring och ända sen man uttagit började med marknadsföring någon gång på Jesu tid.
Det finns ju faktiskt skärvor och sånt där av lerlampor som visar att man gjorde brandade produkter även i Romariket.
Det är lite coolt.
Men man har alltid varit ifrågasatt.
Alltså vad får vi ut av det här?
Vad är liksom return on investment?
Och så har man bråkat på marknadschefen över det här och det har ofta varit innan det digitala så var det svårt och tungt att samla in information om att kunna särskilja kampagneffekter och sånt från annat.
Men när det digitala kom så låg det i Google och alla andra metas intressen att kunna visa att titta vad fint det går.
Så man serverade massa tekniska plattformar som gav väldigt snygga bilder av att titta vad lönsamma de här grejerna är.
Och marknadscheferna sveptes med också för det var så skönt för dem.
Plötsligt kunde de gå in till ledningsgruppen, dra de där grejerna och vi ser så här, kolla, vi sitter här och tjänar pengar åt oss.
Och då blev det liksom så här att alla var, ja, fine, då lämnar vi dig i fred och så tyckte marknadscheferna var skönt och så sitter de vid sidan av och kör de här grejerna.
Och sen så går åren.
Och nu har vi då två saker.
För det första, så har marknadscheferna slutat ens att bli inbjudna till strategiska diskussioner i ledningsgrupper.
De sitter inte där.
Jag har sett många stora företag som säger öppet att marknadschefen är på nivå tre, fyra, för att det förspecialiserar för att platsa i ledningsgruppen.
Du vet ju att du är på gymkompani, du vet hur du är att träna.
Det är lätt att börja käka för mycket socker, och så käkar du ännu mer socker, och så käkar du ännu mer socker.
Du märker det liksom inte vid början, för det är ju så gott och du märker ingen direkt skillnad.
Men sen går du åt helsikten och det är det du har gjort.
Vad är det som har gått åt helsikten förutom för de stackars marknadscheferna som inte får gå på ledningsmöten längre?
Eller vad är det som är rent krasst dåligt för företagen med den här utvecklingen?
Det första jag redan nämnt är att innovationskraften tappas.
Därför att när man inte har någon samordnade initiativ på att verkligen titta på vart är marknaden på väg, då blir det mer att man får hoppas att enssaka höga chefer på något sätt kanaliserar idéer och tar tag i saker.
Men man saknar den här samordnande synen på marknaden.
Så det är ju sig jävligt allvarligt.
Sen om vi tittar på marknadsavdelningen i sig, så är det ju så att det pågår en masslakt på marknadschefer därute.
Jag vet inte hur många som ser det, men alltså jag känner dussintals riktigt duktiga marknadsförelser som går utan jobb.
För att det liksom det finns inga positioner knappt kvar.
Och den tredje grejen är ju att även om man då har trott på den här liksom mera performance-religionen, att allting liksom går att räkna hem, liksom med rena pengar, så har ju de nyckeltalen försämrats oerhört mycket.
Jag har alltså bokstavligt haft kontakt med flera marknadschefer som har sagt så här, jag vet att vi sitter på att göra massa performance-grejer som liksom heter på snabbförsäljning.
Och jag vet att det är för lite som vi gör på varumärkesidan.
Jag behöver hjälp för att ställa om det här.
Tre gånger så har vi diskuterat, gjort frameworks bara att jag ska hjälpa dem och de hinner få sparken innan de kommer igång.
Alltså det är så illa.
Deras nyckeltal som de en gång i tiden kunde gå in till ledningsgrupper med och säga såhär, kolla vad bra det går.
De är nu bedrövliga.
Men nu är det liksom för sent, för nu är det också alla ledningsgrupper banade att se de där tavlorna med KPIs som ska visa att allting bara liksom går så bra.
Och de kan visa dem längre, för att kostnaderna bara har ökat och responsen har gått ner.
Men vad är det stora?
Jag som inte kan så mycket om den här världen, utan för mig är det bara mycket ord och teorier, men jag är liksom inte själv, du vet, jag är liksom inte investerad i det, jag har liksom inte sett det på riktigt om man ska vara sån.
Men ofta hör man ju, jag gissar då, att marknadsföraren pratar om någon slags sån här split kring performance kontra varumärkesarbete, kontra vad ingår i varumärkesarbetet, och vad är det som är så jävla viktigt med det här varumärkesarbetet, vad är det som är, vilka företag gör det bra, vad är det de tjänar på det, vad är den riktiga grejen i varumärkesarbetet.
Jag tycker att det är en grej som jag tror de flesta kan relatera till som är, alltså 35 och över i alla fall, är väl det vad som hände med mobiltelefonundret i Sverige där jag som sagt var med och hade mycket formativa år.
När jag kom med hade ju Ericsson vuxit fram från ingenting på mobiltelefonbranschen inom att man helt enkelt bara hade teknik och kunde utveckla den.
Och just då så växte marknaden enormt bara på grund av att det tekniskt sett gick att göra mobiltelefoner.
Så länge det var drivkraften så gick allting jättebra.
Och så kom man på att man behövde varumärket så man satsade på det.
Man hade marknadsbudget och man gjorde reklam.
Men plötsligt så fick man den där effekten att alla ville ha Nokia.
Varför är det det?
Ja, och folk skällde och höll på på alla möjliga fronter.
Eriksson var bra på teknik och dålig på marknadsföring.
Allting kom egentligen bara från magen där.
Det jag kom på var vilka mobiltelefoner gör vi för vem?
Vem är det som briefar?
Det var ingen som egentligen hade någon centralbild av det, utan det var bara att döka upp i olika mer tekniska chefers huvud.
Eller att en säljchef i Malaisia kom och sa till den tekniker att ni borde göra en sådan här.
Ingen sammanhållande grej.
I det längsta var också motståndet att använder vi inte det är bara på grund av teknikerna som vi finns.
Det är där visionerna finns.
Ni ska inte lägga ifrån marknadsvåldet.
Då blev all den här samordningen.
Det tycker jag är ett väldigt bra exempel.
När Sony Ericsson gick igång, då skulle jag hävda att av naturliga skäl, vi hade nära döden upplevelser, då samlade alla sig.
Vad är det vi håller på med?
Vad är vi till för?
Det är varumärkesbygget i så mycket större utsträckning än att man går till en byrå och säger så här kan ni hitta på någon bra idé som magiskt förlöser oss.
Det har väl hänt att det har haft effekter också, men det är väldigt mycket ett strategiarbete bakom som gör om det här verkligen fungerar.
Så på något sätt så den stora frågan är är produkterna faktiskt till för någon?
Det är inte bara en techspeck utan det är en produkt byggd för någon med dem i åtanke.
Det är det som är den riktiga frågan.
Exakt och det är ju liksom, jag tänker på din bransch är det ju också så att det beror på att man måste hitta sin roll i ekosystemet eller ännu bättre.
Alltså göra om ekosystemet runt den.
Så till exempel ni är jätteduktiga i det ni gör och det är ju liksom ett sätt att spela det här.
Men du har ju hört talas om Pellot naturligtvis som ju liksom skapade en träna hemma-klubb och förändrade och det stämde ju väldigt bra överens under covid också när det var lockdown i många länder.
Att du kunde sitta hemma på träningsyklet men ändå få en gemenskap.
Gymshark till exempel kom ju också från ingenstans och sålde gymkläder på och tänkte bara annorlunda, vi börjar mer i communitykänsla och att du liksom är del i alltså ett gäng som hjälper varandra att träna.
Och sen får du kläderna istället för att göra som det ofta blir tvärtom.
Vi ska kränga kläder, hur ska vi göra?
Ofta är ju de här starka, starka idéerna handlar om att man verkligen förstår var någonstans i ekosystemet passar vi in eller vad är det för saker vi faktiskt förändrar.
Det är också sådant här som man aldrig kan fånga om man bara sitter och stirrar ner på hur man konverterar på TikTok just nu.
Du nämner typ community fast på olika sätt när du pratar om de här olika pelotoner.
Är det en grej?
Är det en viktig grej?
Behöver man bry sig om det?
Varför är det så jävla viktigt?
Alltså det här är ju den roliga grejen i...
Alltså ju längre man håller på med marknadsföring så tycker jag också så här att det finns ingen patentlösning.
Community kan vara allt för ett varumärkes framtid och kan vara en total distraction för en annan.
Men till exempel, jag är jättefascinerad av när jag fattade det, att Airbnb till exempel växte fram inte så mycket för att det var någon teknisk uppfinning i sig att förmedla att vissa vill hyra ut bostäder och andra vill hyra dem.
En av nycklarna var ju att det är en otrygghetssituation för bägge parter.
Vad fan ska du öppna ditt hem åt främlingar?
Då var jag för garantier.
Nej, det här känns läskigt.
Respektive också att resa till ett annat land och bara gå och leta efter en lägenhet kanske.
Gud vet vad som väntar än där.
Och det de fattar, även om de inte pratar så att säga så här att Airbnb är trygghet, så är det så att de löste de där knutarna.
Så det är också det här med ekosystem att förstå vad är det som gör att vi kan ha en annan affärsmodell än vad andra har haft och därmed ge en helt annan upplevelse som farser ner med en to no end.
Så det är inte bara att det är så här, det är alltid en fråga om community eller så, utan det är ju att förstå psykologin och hur olika parter också inom det här agerar för att skapa värde för kunder och andra involverande.
Är det inte det här som är det stora problemet med varumärket som marknadsföringsdiskussioner att väldigt mycket beror bara på, det är väldigt mycket lättare att bara se på att lägga in tusen spänn och få två tusen spänn tillbaka.
Det är ju en...
Nej men det är exakt så.
Det är ju det som jag tycker är mer tragiskt att ta även LinkedIn liksom.
På LinkedIn kan du få kontakt med folk som är hur smarta och kompetenta som helst.
Men ändå är det ju ofta att det som blir viralt är ju antingen fortune cookie wisdom.
Bry det att vara kundfokuserad.
Eller så är det taktiska tips.
Här är tio hacks som gör att folk läser din Instagramrubbe.
Men det är tragiskt.
Men det är ju som det mesta i världen.
Ska man göra någonting riktigt bra så är det ju svårt.
Det är en av tragedierna med marknadsföring.
Vem i helvete har sagt att det ska vara lätt?
Alltså vad är det för idiot?
Det är klart att det är bland det mest bland det mest komplicerade som finns.
Att man ska ta hänsyn till en marknad i full konkurrens, psykologi, teknisk utveckling, företagets resurser och kompetenser och möjligheter.
Få ihop allt det här till någonting som gör en skillnad.
Det är klart att det är kvalificerat fucking arbete.
Men det är alltid folk i rummet som ska reducera ner marknadsföring till.
Så där kan det inte vara.
Och konsulter som ritar någon jävla gyllene cirklar och säger start with Y så blir allt bra.
Så att det där är, ja jag går igång på det här, du märker det.
Jag vill slå någon nu, jag vill slå någon nu.
Nej men det är faktiskt det som har, du vet, vissa tjänar ju också på att spela med i de här dumheterna.
Att bara lova guld och gröna skogar och säga, gör så här så får du så här mycket tillbaka som företagsledare och så vidare.
Jag får varje dag, så är det någon som erbjuder mig då som företagare, att göra massa cold e-mailing.
Vi kan naila ut till 10 000 människor.
Nej men jag vill inte det, därför att jag kanske skulle få ett par kunder på det.
Men jag skulle också få 9 990 arga människor som tycker såhär, fan spämmer du mig för liksom.
Men det här syns inte i liksom den dunna strömmen av liksom enskilda kopier alltså.
Men titta, vi hade return investment där på och liksom 5 000% för att det kostade knappt, det är ingenting att störa hela världen med vårt nonsense och vi fick en kuld.
Är det så, om det funkar då, är det så negativt?
Om man är okej med att vara lite hatad typ.
Ja men alltså det finns ju sådana exempel och nu måste jag tänka snabbt här.
Jag har skrivit en hel del om, om man ser den vetenskapliga sidan också bakom att provocera och sådana här saker.
Det finns liksom lite sådana effekter av exempelvis allt det här halabaluet kring Sidney Sweeney och hennes jeans och sånt där.
Att när reaktionerna kommer ifrån ett håll där folk i allmänhet tycker att reaktionerna är löjliga, då vinner man ju liksom, man får ju en jäkla gratis spridning på grejerna och så reagerar folk med att säga att herregud, vad håller de på med, tagga ner och då får du ju liksom sympatipoäng.
Men det där är en svår balansgång därför att gör du det flera gånger då blir det också ett kontroversiellt varumärke.
Och där visar faktiskt empirin att folk vill inte ha kontroversiell varumärke.
Okej, vissa människor tycker att det är jättekul att köpa t-shirts om det står såhär provokativa saker på ungefär.
Men när din logga blir så, då kommer bara halvtokiga människor att vara bekväma med det och då kommer de att sticka.
Så att, nej, generellt sett så är det faktiskt en ganska...
Jag tror man ska vara ganska nykter kring det där.
Man ska inte tro att man får för mycket på att vara kontroversiell eller bara göra grejer och säga att det är skitsamma.
Därför att det skapar tillväxthinder som du kan undvika.
Två frågor egentligen.
Men finns det något eller några varumärken som du tycker är jävligt bra, som gör det långsiktigt jävligt bra och du säger de har hittat sin modell, de gör detta år efter år och de bygger ett bra varumärke.
Och sen finns det något varumärke som du känner är jävligt bra på att balansera det här kontroversiella.
Alltså det har varit intressant att se om det finns någon som så här, fan de lyckas ändå vara lite, fan det är inte helt bra men de får det att funka liksom, de växer.
Det där är en intressant fråga, men vet du jag ska faktiskt vara jobbig och vända på det och säga så här, ju mer man jobbar med det här desto mer ser jag, alltså har jag också märkt att det är väldigt farligt att säga så här, kolla på dem där, de här gör det bra.
Och det är av två skäl.
Det första är att väldigt få företag är konsekvent, superbra.
Alla ligger på en grå skala, alla gör bort sig lite.
Ibland går de helt bort sig även strategiskt.
Nike var ju en gång i tiden så här, man kunde alltid peka på dem och säga så här, de där, så där ska man köpa ett varumärke.
Sen ballar de liksom.
Så det är ju en sak.
Den andra grejen som är farlig är att alla bedömer varumärkena då när man berättar om dem, utifrån sin egen upplevelse och sin magkänsla, jättefarligt.
Det är en av grejerna jag har märkt, jag jobbar väldigt mycket internationellt.
Och en av hindren tycker jag är att när svenskar tänker på varumärken så blir vi faktiskt väldigt svenska.
Vi tänker på vår svenska tillvaro och vårt samhälle.
Jag sitter här i Brasilien, det är ju helt annorlunda härute.
Totalt, det är faktiskt en av anledningarna till att jag inte bor i Sverige, det är för att jag liksom vill ha den här.
Vi kanske ska säga att det är lite palm och vatten i bakgrunden.
Jag förstår att det inte är riktigt, men det är i alla fall palm och vatten i bakgrunden.
Ja, jag tycker det passar även om jag faktiskt bor 100 mil från Atlanten.
Jag bor i inlandet nära Brasilien, men palmarna har vi.
Papagojerna flyger fritt till stan.
Det svåra är att vi bedömer varumärken utifrån vår egna livserfarenhet.
Det är många kreatörer som tycker att det är toppen och tycker att det är så man ska göra.
Som strateg tycker jag att det är jättefarligt.
Man ska vara så pass kylig att man tittar på sig.
Men vad vet vi faktiskt?
Kunden är inte jag.
Det försvinner väldigt fort när man ger folk exempel.
Då blir de helt carried away.
De tittar på grejer och säger att de tycker att de är skitsamma.
Det var inte poängen.
För att förstå de här grejerna så måste man ändå upp på en teoretisk nivå.
Varför tycker du att det där är bra?
Vad är det de gör?
Har du fler exempel på att det funkar?
Ganska fort så märker man att det är rätt farligt.
Det är det frässande.
Man går in till en ledningsgrupp och de säger exakt det här.
Kan du ge ett exempel?
Men då slingrar jag mig.
För att det leder tanken fel.
I värsta fall, och det har ju alltså hänt där, då är det så att de bara, ja då kopierar vi det.
Vi använder typ samma slogan.
Då rasar allt.
Så att det är svårt att resonera i exempel faktiskt.
Hur flummi måste man bli som sån här, någon sorts varumärkeskonsult?
Måste man in och börja prata?
För att man inte ska kopiera andras marknadsföring, varumärkesarbete och allt sånt där.
Måste man börja med, vad är viktigt för er?
Start with your wise, och som du pratade om.
Hur djupgående måste det där vara innan man kan sätta igång?
Får man hålla på och skifta under tiden?
Eller kan man hoppa lite fram och tillbaka?
Hur funkar det i arbetet?
Jag kan faktiskt berätta om det ganska konkret.
Det är alltid så när du möter en organisation, att, tror eller ej, men mer inte bättre när man konsultar.
Kommer du in med, du har säkert sett det på olika ställen, och drar du 50 powerpointslides för folk, då zonar de bort.
De ser ingen skog, de ser bara en massa bla bla bla.
När jag har kokat ner en reduktion, som det heter i matlagningen, på vad är det egentligen för managementgrejer du behöver ha i ett företag, så är det i min starka övertygelse, det är i princip bara fyra saker.
Det första är att du behöver en affärsstrategi.
Denna affärsstrategi är inte allt, utan det är vilka bets gör du när du och Joel driver Junko på dig.
Vad är det du har gjort för beslut som kommer att ha effekter på ett par års sikt, som gör att du har lite ont i magen också, för du kan ha fel.
Det är den egentliga strategin.
Det andra kan man strunta i och dra, såvitt folk inte behöver fakta och sånt där.
Men det är ju att förmedlar man dels förmedlar man en strategi, och många företag är jättedåliga på det, men där behöver du ha öronkoll.
Ett sätt att få öronkoll och också rama in det här till någonting som är mer än att tjäna pengar, det är att man behöver en vision.
Och det är att bortom liksom vår planeringshorisat, vad är det egentligen vi tycker att vi vill?
Och den är viktig för att de flesta som jobbar i ett företag kommer aldrig orka sätta sig in och tänka på affärsstrategi.
Så att man behöver någon summerande tanke som ändå alla fattar går igång på.
Och som också beskriver lite grann vad är det för värde vi gör för folk utanför det här företaget.
Och det leder in på den tredje, och det är en varumärkesstrategi.
För varumärkesstrategin är ju liksom i långa loppet så här, vad betyder det här för folk utifrån?
Varför ska jag bry mig om det här?
Vad är det jag får?
Och vad är det jag, vad är värt för mig att minnas om det här företagets värdeskapande?
Och den fjärde grejen det är kultur och det är i princip att kunna de här tre grejerna, andra grejerna jag sa.
Alltså vart företaget ska, vad de huvudsakliga betsen är på hur man ska ta sig dit och vilka värde man skapar och varför man ska bli håkommen utifrån.
Det är ju egentligen det som bygger en internkultur.
Har man de fyra grejerna klara för sig, då är det bra.
Och hur gör man det då?
Ja alltså det är ju klart att det måste man ju göra utifrån den man gör det för.
När jag har gjort det här för börsbolag, då är det ju liksom en process som faktiskt kan ta något år liksom.
För att man behöver gå igenom alla grejer, det ska vara undersökningar i olika marknader och så vidare.
Gör man det för ett lite mindre företag i Sverige, då får man acceptera så här att man får ju rätta sig efter storlek och vad man har att jobba med.
Och då får man ju liksom tillsammans bestämma sig för att är vi bekväva med att göra det här även om vi inte vet.
Vi måste liksom tro.
Men i ett nötskal är det så jag har jobbat hela tiden.
Att jag säkerställer det här.
Och det är ju en annan grej, man gör aldrig det här i princip från noll.
De här grejerna finns ju.
Men om du ser det här som en kedja så är det ofta så att vissa delar är mycket svagare.
Så om det är så att man har en jävligt bra idé på varumärkesmässigt, vad man ska vara i marknaden, och det är inget fel på det.
Men man kanske affärsstrategiskt inte alls tar konsekvenserna av vad man tänker där.
Då måste man diskutera det.
Så det är inte så mycket som jag tror folk kan tro att man alltid gör det här jättelinjärt och gör om allting i grunden.
Utan det är ju liksom bara så att in och köta i det som faktiskt finns men fundera på hur man kan flytta schackpjäserna så att man har någonting mycket bättre och mycket solidare.
Vad skulle du säga att företag oftast fallerar inom?
Vad är det som är eftersatt när det kommer till egentligen allt som rör marknadsföring?
Alltså jag skulle nog säga i de här grejerna att jag tror att många företag väldigt fortfastnar i att dels att det är mer operations än det är marknad.
Man bara tänker mer på att bara allting bara fortsätter att snurra och man ser inte att det kan vara minst lika farligt att bara fortsätta att göra som man gjorde förra året.
Som att säga nej men vi gör om de här sakerna.
För vi tror att marknaden kommer att röra på sig och därför så gör vi saker annorlunda.
Det finns liksom en bias hela tiden i att man gör liksom mindre och det brukar också vara så att säga att man har i Sverige till exempel en överriven konsensuskultur.
Att om inte alla är med på precis allt så blir det liksom ungefär att den mest motsträvige liksom lägger hinder för momentum.
Och det tycker jag massor av människor ska liksom ha med sig.
Och en annan grej i marknadsföring är att alla rasar ner i att de ska tycka till exempel om hur reklamen ser ut och sånt där.
Och det är verkligen så här, jag tror du förstår det vid det här laget, jag är ofta inte så super ego-investerad i hur man kommunicerar.
Men jag önskar verkligen förutom fattade, att det gör så mycket skada när amatörer lägger sig i hur man uttrycker saker och hur man skapar saker.
Ni blir bara tråkigare, ni förlorar bara pengar på det.
Alltså, stoppa folk från att ha så att säga hjälpsamma åsikter om hur man gör marknadskommunikation.
För det är väl också ett sådant där jättemistag.
Brukar det vara vd-ar eller mellanchefer eller vem är det som brukar ha de här åsikterna?
Som känner att jag måste också få säga min åsikt.
Man måste vara tyst.
Nidbilden är ju liksom den gammaldags småkorpulenta vdn vars fru har haft en åsikt.
Att hon gillade inte gult.
Det har hänt i ett stort företag.
Att man tog bort färgen gult från ett jätteinitiativ för att hon gillade inte gult.
Det har hänt.
Men jag skulle säga faktiskt att det är farligare med massa riskaversiva mellanchefer.
Det kommer marknadsmänniskor som tyvärr ofta är så kuva att de ska alltid visa grejer för folk som inte har en aning.
Och så visar de för lite mellanchef, vad tycker du om det här?
Och så ska de hjälpa till då.
Eller rättare sagt att de går ofta på det här väldigt instinktiva, att det är ofta riskaversivt.
De vill inte säga någonting som betyder något, för det blir läskigt.
Och så blömer de att allting handlar ju om att kommunikation handlar ju om att något ska förändras och smottagas.
Annars är det ju inte kommunikation.
Då är det ju tapeter, eller hur?
Hissmusik.
Hur fria tyglar ska marknadsförare få ha, eller de som har hand om den strategin, så att inte, jag tänker att de kanske inte ska bestraffas direkt för att man måste få lite kreativ frihet, men det kan ju också balla ur om man inte har något ansvar.
Vart går gränsen kring hur mycket man får leka med företagets känsla, liksom?
Nej men alltså jag är radikal.
Alltså antingen så har du anställt bra människor för att göra det jobbet och då ska de göra det hundra procent.
Annars ska du fan ta ansvar också för utfallet, men det gör de ju inte.
Alltså jag har sett hur många gånger som helst, apropå det här också att marknadschefen har blivit markkommschef för mig, men de måste, de har siffrorna, de har hundra procent ansvar för att saker fungerar och att folk ser grejerna, att folk reagerar på det, att det ringer i kassapparaten.
Alla de här grejerna har de ansvar för, men kreativt så har de inte befogenheten att bara säga så att det här ska vi köra, utan då lägger sig alla i, men då helt utan ansvar för utfallet.
Det är ju egentligen helt otroligt att det förhåller sig på det sättet.
Men nej, jag skulle säga att du måste ha förtroende för, när du kommer ut mot kommunikation, så måste du ha förtroende för den som är ansvarig för det.
Eller så får du helt enkelt byta den personen.
Det finns inget mellanting därför att då skapar man ju den här grejen att de börjar göra grejer för dig istället för kunden.
Där kommer över tid miljoner inna mellan fingrarna.
Så det är ett vanligt minstål.
Om man ska bli riktigt duktig på att förstå marknad, vad är det man ska fatta då?
Är det liksom beteendeterapi eller är det att bli duktig på att förstå paketering av tjänster och produkter eller är det att förstå makrolandskapet?
Du får inte säga allt för det är liksom inte det jag letar efter.
Vad är det man inte lär sig som man borde lära sig?
Det här kanske är lite oväntat men jag tycker faktiskt att många marknadsförare är marknadsföring skadade av att de lär sig marknadsföring just genom att de sitter och pillar digitalt med grejer.
I Australien och i Storbritannien så vet vi att hälften av de som är marknadsföring har ingen formell utbildning överhuvudtaget i det området.
Men man plockar lite här och där och som sagt det är väldigt ofta på fortune cookie wisdom nivå.
Det är som du vet sådana här planscher med ylande vargar och örar på klippor.
Det är så tentigt liksom.
Men de försöker pussla ihop någon egen snickrad teori.
Så att till marknadsförare så är det så här, nummer ett, gå en riktig utbildning.
Vad ville du säga?
Gå en riktig jävla utbildning, ja det är okej att svära.
Men sen så är det faktiskt en grej som jag också ska säga också lite som kritik även mot universitet och sådant där.
Det är faktiskt att nummer ett för att förstå marknadsföring, det är faktiskt att förstå business.
Inte det här att det är enbart en separat grej som sagt med kommunikation och psykologi där.
Det är viktigt också.
Men om man bara håller på med det, då måste det finnas en person som förstår businesskontexten av detta.
Det här har en del byråfolk faktiskt jättesvårt att förstå tycker jag.
De tror att de kan business, men det är faktiskt inte sant i många fall.
Utan de kan liksom en bit bakåt där de är van att jobba.
Men man blir faktiskt en väldigt mycket bättre marknadsförare på att förstå till och med sådana här saker som du kämpar med varje dag, har jag sett, med logistik, lagerhållning, hur stor är genomsnittsvården?
Alla de här sakerna är otroligt viktiga pusselbitar.
Många som är marknadsförare hamnar ju i det här att de är aldrig så involverade och det gör de tillsammans med marknadsförare.
Så jag skulle säga, som sagt, att nummer ett är naturligtvis skaffa en formell utbildning i marknadsföring.
Du behöver ju inte gå tillbaka till ett universitet.
Det finns olika sätt att göra det online och sånt där också.
Men var också mycket mer intresserad av affärer.
Lär dig läsa årsredovisningar och sånt där.
Bara att läsa om årsredovisning på ett företag, om de finns publicerade, så kan man ju liksom mer än 90% av de som jobbar i företaget kan.
För att det står ju en jäkla massa saker där som folk inte ens är medvetna om internt, märkligt nog.
Och det gör en vettel.
Kunde du det när du var på Ericsson?
Ja alltså det är ju väl en så att säga, en acquired grej att man liksom mer och mer förstår affärsperspektivet.
Men jo men i någon mån va.
Jag menar vi satt ju till exempel och gjorde forecasting för att det var så otroligt viktigt att bara liksom till exempel se hur utvecklas ekonomin i världen just nu.
Därför att när alla ville ha mer och mer mobiltelefoner så var det ju så att ju bättre ett land gick desto ännu mer mobiltelefoner skulle man vilja ha.
Och det gjorde ju liksom att det styrde planering och så vidare.
Så man blev ganska fort tvungen att ha koll på väldigt mycket sådana här faktorer som inte traditionellt hamnar inom marknadsföring, så att säga i den där kommunikationsperspektiven.
Om man tar ett litet bolag som mitt eget här, jag använder det som exempel.
Vi har ju liksom ingen marknadsföringsroll, vi använder ju en performancebyrå som jag då och då hör av mig till och säger hej ska du vara lite för du vet, spänden.
Så att vi gör ju alltid det här.
Sen blir det ju såklart, vi är ett litet bolag och då sitter man ju själv givetvis och tänker på mycket av de här frågorna kring hur vi ska uppfattas.
Vilken kund köper vi in nu, vad är det för sortiment vi gör och vem ska det här riktas.
Alltså det är klart att vi tänker lite grann på det men vi gör ju det inte på ett, vi har ju inget språk för att beskriva det så det blir ju alltid på ett, vad ska man säga, ett halvt sätt.
Om jag hade fått in någon som verkligen var duktig på marknadsföring till gymkompaniiet, och jag fattar att du inte har någon koll på oss, men du vet, ett vanligt E&Ls litet bolag sådär, och så kom man in som marknadsförare, vad tror du de hade blivit mest fascinerade över?
Har ni inte tänkt på detta eller fan, vilken jävla...
Fan vad klantig liksom.
Har ni inte...
Alltså det är ju jättesvårt att säga, men en klassiker är ju just att om ni kör väldigt mycket performance, så är det ju att man konverterar ju mycket bättre på performance om man har ett känt varumärke.
Och den faktorn kan ju typ vara såhär fyra gånger liksom, mer.
Om man balanserar på det lite, så man bygger varumärken för alla de som just nu inte tänker på att köpa någonting från er, men som minser den dagen de vill köpa någonting.
Så jag kan tänka mig kanske att det är en av de liksom lägst hängande frukterna skulle vara en kalibrering av det och att få ut liksom vad gymkompaniet tillför så att man liksom med förhoppningsvis nästan ett leende på läpparna ser era annonser och kommer ihåg er, har er i åtanke den dagen man behöver någonting i er område.
Sen så är det väl liksom, tror jag också att man om man jobbar som ja så skulle det liksom mer vara marknadsmixen.
Givet att ni liksom ser allt det här och vem ni säljer till och varför och så vidare, hur hänger det här ihop?
Hur paketerar man grejer?
Till den kundgruppen?
Hur klargör man var egentligen är man till för värden?
Alla sådana faktorer och jag brukar säga liksom att hävstången är ju ofta högre, ju längre upp liksom i affärerna, i strategin man går, ju mer hävstång får du ju liksom på den kommersiella sidan, om du hittar någonting som skaver mot vad marknaden egentligen vill ha och se liksom ripe for the taking.
En annan grej som jag tycker är jävla kul, som fascinerar mig oerhört mycket just nu, det är att tillväxt kommer alltså till någonstans mellan två tredjedelar till typ 80 och till och med 90 procent beroende på branscher och kontext, så kommer inte det av att man snor marknadsandelar, utan att marknaden växer.
Så det är ju till exempel att ni vet att under covid så fick väl ni förmodligen en hel sving av folk som ville träna hemma och köpte prylar av er.
Det var nästan svårt att inte sälja.
Ja exakt.
Och sen får man liksom baksmälla för sen efteråt då har man liksom mättat den marknaden.
Vissa uppskattningar är helt plötsligt att ungefär en tredjedel av sådana här rising tides och sen falling tides.
Går det liksom att orkestrera själv?
Genom att man till exempel skulle såhär, det är enklare än vad man tror byggat hemma, gym eller så här kom det igång.
Alla de här klassiska marknadsbyggarna.
Och det finns mycket mer revenue att hämta för många företag i att skita i konkurrenterna.
Bara tänka på såhär, hur får vi folk att få nya beteenden genom att visa och hitta nya sätt att introducera det.
Och där ligger tillväxten.
Det är en annan sak som också faller bort hur alla de här mer taktiskt låsta marknadsföranden som bara kan sitta och tänka såhär, vad ska vi skriva nu då så att folk klickar på den här jävla knappen.
Utan att mer tänka att, ja men, kan vi forma marknaden?
Kan vi hjälpa till att plaska i vattnet så att det uppstår en våg?
Jag fattar, ja men vi, istället för att tänka på dagens kund så ska man ta liksom första skörden av nästa års kund.
Eller hur ska jag kalla det?
Innan vi behöver konkurrera om den så behöver vi redan ha gjort dem färdiga.
Okej, jag fattar, jag gillar det helt enkelt.
Forskningen säger ju liksom att du bygger inte, för att växa så måste du få in nya kunder, därför att det är väldigt svårt att bygga, bygga liksom mera försäljning hela tiden på en ökad lojalitet på befintliga kunder.
Ni har väl säkert några stållar som liksom har lagt ett par hundratusen på att ha ett hemmagym, men det är inte så jävla många som är det.
Dessutom paradoxalt nog så är de ofta inte lojala heller, därför att de är ju så nördiga så att de känner ju till alla era konkurrenter och köper precis vad de vill ha just då för bästa priset av de här sakerna.
Utan paradoxalt nog så är det ju ofta så här den stora marknaden kan vara att börja nå folk som idag inte tror att de kan träna och inte kan komma igång av olika anledningar.
Så hittar ni liksom, vad är det som håller dem tillbaka och hur kan ni nå dem och hur kan ni sälja ett par grejer till dem?
Och därmed liksom få en, alltså öka penetrationen i populationen och sedan växa därifrån.
Sådant där tycker jag också är skitintressant liksom för att det finns också en grej som måste bli lite filosofisk men marknadsföringen har ju liksom blivit i sin grundsyn så där liksom nästan, du vet, rovkapitalistisk.
Vi måste slå ihjäl konkurrenterna.
Men ser man på siffrorna som sagt så är det väldigt lite att hämta där.
Det är inte där man faktiskt får in pengarna.
Så det är lite lustigt, många är helt obsessiva på marknadsandelar men till slutet av dagen när du går hem och ska betala dina räkningar så betalar du inte räkningarna med marknadsandelen.
Du betalar ju det med dina intäkter och din marginal.
Så där finns det också så här felslut som en del företag hamnar i.
Att de blir så statiska också att de tänker bara på hur ska vi stoppa vår konkurrent.
Jag vet inte vad det heter på svenska untappt market eller hela blue ocean, alltså du vet sådär, fast man menar det kanske på en lite mer alltså det behöver inte alltid bli så att man ska uppfinna hjulet eller göra en enorm grej, utan det handlar bara kanske om att paketera det på ett sätt så att man når en procent som, alltså i år behöver vi bara nå en procent av en marknad som vi skulle kunna bli kunder någon gång men som inte är riktigt redo än.
Alltså man måste inte alltid göra det så jävla stort.
Nej och en annan grej som jag tycker är intressant det är att innovation då, det är ju, vi har också fått en mental spärr i näringslivet att innovation, det är high tech.
Och så tänker man så är det sådant man håller på med i Silicon Valley och liksom på uppstarts scenen då vi har i Sverige också.
Men liksom för vanliga bolag så är det omöjligt att vara riktigt innovativa.
Men det är också ett fel slutet för att alla företag idag, jag menar ni har hur mycket teknik som helst, alla företag bygger på teknik.
Airbnb var ju liksom inte ett tech play, det var ju bara att man hittade sätt att skapa ett nytt koncept.
Naturligtvis så hade det varit svårt att göra utan den här teknologin, men tekniken är ju i sig bara parity, det är ingenting speciellt i det.
Det är samma sak idag, att du kan använda AI, det är inte liksom i sig att du använder AI, alla kommer att använda AI.
Så det är liksom mer så här, hur passar det här in?
Vad är det vi kan göra nu som vi inte kunde göra för er?
Och det jag märker, för det här har jag gjort en så att säga en form av forskningsrapport på faktiskt, att jag tittade på 150 företag som har växt så in i vassen de senaste tio åren.
Och liksom letat efter vad de har gjort.
Och då ser man ganska tydligt att de har tagit befintliga behov, men adderat någonting som till exempel när vi pratade om Pellot de tidigare eller Gymshark, bägge de är med på den listan förut.
Och det som händer då är också psykologiskt att ditt varumärke blir mer av ett egen ord i folks huvud.
Det är liksom jobb, alltså ingen förklarar riktigt vad till exempel Airbnb gör.
Utan det är lättare att bara säga, nej men vi bor på Airbnb.
Aha, säger folk.
Och då har du liksom, det är väldigt Blue Ocean strategy-mässigt också, fast de menar mer strategiskt.
Det jag har kommit på är att det här är faktiskt psykologiskt och även linguistiskt, hur nya ord kommer till.
När vi pratar om Brain Rot eller doomscrolling idag, så är det ju för att jag har uppsett ett nytt beteende som har en lite komplex innebörd, men det är jobbigt att förklara det varje gång.
Så då är det lättare att säga så här, jag ligger bara här och doomscrollar, så fatta folk.
Om ditt varumärke fyller in en liknande roll, då får du ett enormt momentum.
Och jag jobbar med Swish till exempel, och de har ju verkligen gjort det.
Alltså det är ju ingen som liksom börjar förklara så här, men du då ska jag betala dig här med min Fintech applikation.
Utan man säger bara så här, men du jag swishar dig.
Det är där man ska vara.
Och det är inte en tech-grej.
Det är det jag kommer tillbaka till.
Många tappar ambitionen här och säger att det där kan bara tech-bolag gör.
Nej, absolut inte.
Det där handlar bara om att man inte har orkat leta efter, alltså att utvidga sitt territorium på ett sätt som har blivit psykologiskt intressant för folk.
Så det är också en grej jag jobbar med.
Jag pratade med någon annan, vad kallar man det, någon marknadsföringsminister.
Men då, för att förringa hans titel.
Men då pratade han mycket om att man vill äga händelser, så som till exempel IKEA äger om man flyttar hemifrån.
Då är det liksom, då måste du gå till IKEA.
Och ska du åka utomlands och du ska bo utomlands, då bor du ju antingen på hotell eller så går du på Airbnb.
Du letar inte upp en konkurrent till Airbnb, alltså det är väl ingen som ens, det är inte så man tänker i huvudet.
Så jag bara gillar det här att man äger sin kategori eller man äger området.
Så man blir en av de två alternativen som finns.
Det är som, jag har ju små barn som vi ska äta och vi är stressade, då går vi till McDonalds eller något annat.
Så McDonalds är inte en av restaurangerna, det finns McDonalds och det finns det andra.
Och de får liksom slåss om resten på något sätt.
Nej men det är precis så, jag tycker att det här är kul för att det finns marknadsföraren nu som har köpt vissa bitar av teoriutvecklingen som är rätt naturligtvis på vissa sätt.
Att om man säger så här, folk bryr sig inte om varumärken säger de.
Och det finns siffror på det.
Så tittar man så här, vad är det de inte bryr sig om?
Det är typ Ica eller Coop eller det är köpa Kelloggs eller köpa ENV eller bo på Hilton eller bo på Hyatt.
Och så säger de triumforiskt så här, titta, alla är switchers, alla köper och inbördes insimellan.
Och det visar sig att det finns ingenting att se här, du måste ha en annonsbudget och du måste ligga och tjata om att när du tänker på frukostflingor, tänker på keller och så vidare.
Det är en väldigt trist bild, men jag tycker också att den är rent farlig, därför att det blir så, då låser du tanken vid, alltså att det är så här världen ser ut, och ingenting kan vi göra åt det.
Om jag ska välja mellan Hyatt och Hilton, så blir det skitsamma, eller hur?
Men om jag däremot säger så ska jag bo på Hilton, eller ska jag bo på Airbnb, då är det två helt olika upplevelser, och det vet jag.
Då kan det liksom vara, och då blir valet, det blir nästan självklart att jag kommer att välja Hilton, om jag ska göra det här, och vill jag ha den här upplevelsen, så kommer jag att köra på Airbnb.
Jag jobbar efter den andra grejen, och att hitta kommersiella verkligheter som blir starkare än att man bara sitter och funderar på exakt hur stor chokladbit ska vi lägga på kudden om vi är i hajjet.
Så jag tror att du förstår vad jag benar här.
Man kan ha rätt, empiriskt, och ändå ha så jävla fel om en blir en rådgivare som säger åt sina kunder att allt i princip är hopplöst, du kan bara sitta här och paddla runt i samma damm i några decennier till och hoppas att ingen gör samma tråkiga saker ännu bättre än vad du gör.
Att försöka växa genom att undvika misstag och riskvinimera och i princip bara göra allting tråkigt.
Min erfarenhet har varit, för jag har varit med om det mot dussingånger, företag som verkligen har stuckit iväg.
Och dessutom har jag varit med om företag som har blivit krossade också tyvärr.
Det är inte så behagligt.
Och jag kan aldrig släppa det att man måste jobba med att skapa sin egen framtid.
Inte liksom att bara sitta och stilla i en statisk kategori och förvalta.
Men måste man alltid återuppfinna kategorier?
Kan man inte bara förstärka sin kategori?
Kan man inte bara få vara någon jävla gång?
Man kan ju tycka det men jag tror att problemet är just att i princip är ju kategori och commodity du vet.
Kategori är ju i princip definierat från första början av Nielsen och de här som av olika anledningar för att det var praktiskt för livsmedelsbranschen.
Att på något sätt måste du bygga en livsmedelsbutik.
Du kan ju inte ha ett kaos.
Så sorteringsprincipen blev en grej man kallar kategori.
Det här betyder ju inte att kunder har det här i huvudet ens.
Det här var startpunkten också när alla började fundera på att allting ska in i kategorier och så ska man sitta och jämföra sig med marknadsandelar och sånt där.
Och jag skulle säga att det är inte ens lugnt och skönt.
Därför att det som händer är ju naturligtvis en sån konkurrenssituation.
Att ju längre tid du sitter still i det där, desto mer blir du en commodity.
Du blir ersättningsbar.
Faktum är att idag så är just Nilsson-definitionen också.
Det är att du är fullständigt utbytbar mot dina konkurrenter.
Och det är ju liksom det sista man vill vara.
Så problemet är ju där lite så här att du vet ju ungefär som att säga att det vore inte skönt för dig som vd att bara softa lite, jobba halv dag, gå hem tidigt.
Det är liksom motsvarighet.
Det är det jag tycker är marknadsföringens motsvarighet.
Vi sitter bara i kategorin och vi pratar bara om kategorigeneriska fördelar.
Och så försöker vi att få våra färger och bli järnkända med de andras färger.
Hade jag en sån marknadschef hade fired a lazy motherfucker.
Hehehehe, som sista fråga då.
När du kommer in som konsult till ett företag, hur ofta är du omtyckt av mer än hälften efter en vecka eller två?
Haha, fan, underbar fråga.
Nej men jag ska faktiskt säga på riktigt att det är två grejer.
Som konsult får man väldigt snabbt ta ställning.
Är jag här för att folk ska tycka om mig eller för att det ska bli bra?
Det är faktiskt väldigt många konsulter allertalat som gör det valet.
Att den som är uppdragsgivare får den totala lojaliteten.
Vad vill du att vi ska komma fram till?
De erkänner inte men det är precis som jobbar.
Jag gör inte det.
Av olika anledningar så märker det jag ganska tidigt att jag måste säga så här att jag kommer bara säga att om det här är mitt företag så...
Och det är också för att jag orkar inte mer politik.
Alltså på riktigt.
Jag fixar inte det.
Jag tycker det är skälsdödande att sitta och fundera på vad kommer den människan vilja höra?
Men med det sagt så skulle jag faktiskt vilja påstå att de flesta tenderar att tycka om mig, inte för att jag är så jäkla glad och trevlig och jovialisk, utan för att när grejerna faller på plats i företaget så mår folk mycket bättre.
De blir mycket mer motiverade, glada, saker lossnar.
Man kommer in med den här tredjepersonseffekten också, att gamla sudegar och skelettigarderoberna trillar ur, för det är en annan person som kommer in och bara ja ja ja men nu gör vi så, vad skönt, nu var det någon som städade upp det där.
Så inte alls sett to my own credit så skulle jag säga så här att jag blir ju ofta rätt populär faktiskt just av att grejer lossnar.
Så det är ju kul.
Och sen så tror jag om jag får slå mig för böset också, i den här världen så är liksom varannan människa liksom och hennes hund är ju strateg liksom.
Men det är faktiskt mycket svårare än vad man kan tro det drog för.
Alltså det är ju att man drar ju egentligen ner nästan oändlig komplexitet.
Och om man har förmågan, om man har erfarenheter av att man har gjort det där liksom bra många gånger förut, tvärs över alla möjliga kontexter och industrier och sånt där, om man kan få ner det här till någonting som folk faktiskt kan relatera till, man vågar ta bort och säga så här att det är det här vi ska göra.
Det är rätt magiskt.
Och det är också en sån här grej som blir väldigt förlösande därför att de flesta kommer aldrig riktigt dit.
Även om man inte har de här surdegarna och allt det där som jag säger, så är det att det är så mycket som skiljer från att göra det halvbra och lite konsensusmässigt ta in vad alla tycker och summera det, till att det liksom är mer så att nej, vi måste göra ett par riktigt svåra vägval.
Men då kommer det att bli så mycket tydligare också hur vi gör allting och då kommer saker att flytta på mycket bättre.
Så det är liksom, det är en grej som jag ändå måste säga så att jag fattar nu hur svårt det är därför att, du vet det är så lätt man nedvärderar det man gör själv lite grann, att man tycker det man själv bemäst för det är inte så jävla svårt.
Och annat, det är svårt.
Men jag ser ju också hur stor skillnad det i princip alltid är mot när jag kommer in och man har gjort grejer sådär liksom till 75 procent.
Och så försöker man liksom sätta det här så att det är på 98 procent.
Och det är mycket mycket mycket större och det gör en väldigt stor skillnad.
Jag gillar det, det tog 30 år och sen kände jag att fan, det är rätt svårt jobb det här faktiskt.
Jag har precis 15 år att ta undervisat på universitet, doktorsgrad, jobba med 150 företag och då börjar man så att det är faktiskt ganska, det är inte så jävla lätt som det ser ut kanske.
Mats, jag vill tacka enormt för kanske det mest filosofiska samtal jag har haft i podden.
Vad kul!
Ja men det, jag har nog aldrig suttit och så här diskuterat så mycket eller pratat om begrepp.
Jag tycker ofta att det blir lite bajsenödigt när man sitter och liksom pratar om vad är det här och så här men jag jag fick faktiskt med mig en del.
Vad roligt.
Just det här med, just det här med m, vad ska man kalla det, jag vet inte vad jag ska kalla det här begreppet som du pratade om men det här med att man går in i en marknad som inte riktigt är kanske redo än men man tar dem innan konkurrenterna tar dem.
Jag kommer kalla det en procents untapped-principen eller något sånt där i mitt huvud.
Men den kommer jag nog att ligga och tänka på en del idag, på riktigt liksom.
Så ett stort tack för att du var med på den.
Jag hoppas andra fick också med sig någonting.
Tusen tack.
Jag gillar, jag pratade med någon annan, vad kallar man det då?
Någon marknadsföringsminister.
Men då, då, då...
För att förringa hans titel.